alles klar war letztens auf dem kanal
von zwei mit des jungen hatte unserem
video gesehen du wirst niemals glauben
was zugleich sieht geist auf kamera und
habe mir dann gedacht okay der verarscht
hat seine zuschauer im jahr muss das
video drüber machen
nee eigentlich finde ich den ganz witzig
und hab ich also ein paar andere sachen
an diesem video hier gesehen wo ich
dachte okay das geht überhaupt nicht
klar was er da macht dieses video her
geht braucht nicht klar dass wie geht
überhaupt nicht da dachte ich mir
wirklich als ich diese ganzen dinge
gesehen habe sei mit dessen muss
gestoppt werden
wir befinden uns hier auf einem kanal
der wohl besten youtuber deutschland das
ist auf jeden fall ein kanal mitnehmen
kann man sich wirklich im
internationalen vergleich rühmen
wieso bin ich bei ähnliche kanäle
goodman
alter schwede was muss sich verändern
damit ich da nicht mehr angezeigt werde
aber zurück zum thema meine damen und
herren er hat vor einiger zeit ein video
hochgeladen vor zwei tagen leute oft
liter denn hoch etwa zwei tagen ein
video hochgeladen du wirst niemals
glauben was du gleich siehste geist auf
kamera und dann schöner roter kreis hier
unmöglich überhaupt nichts gegen den
titel oder gegen den kreis es ist mir
eigentlich scheißegal
weil ich selber auf solche videos und
solches handelsmarke wenn es denn auch
wirklich passiert
und naja ich meine schon einfach mal
rein und ich habe keiner was ich sagen
sollte
ich weiß nicht ob man das gesehen meine
freunde hier
ich meine ein bisschen hoffnung ist noch
da dass es sich hier wirklich um eine
echte was ist das denn jetzt hier die
schauen uns erst mal die tags an und
zwar just really goes top five ghosts
video warum top five ghosts video spot
on tape postings und kämmerer konnte
trieb
also er versucht damit international
zuschauer abzugreifen die jetzt nach top
five ghosts videos suchen
du hast sie kein video von top five
ghosts videos compilation was auch immer
was hochgeladen joshua weise die das
sondern von einem scheiß löffel
da besteht und geringer unterschied aber
freude ich weiß ich habe das selber
keine weiße weste was da an geht also
nicht gar nicht so viel strengen
deswegen hab ich auch schon gesagt als
ich nur das gesehen habe habe ich mir
gedacht da muss ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt video zu machen denn wir
schauen uns mal die beschreibung hier an
ich habe euch ja schon aber die komische
dinge hier erzählt aber dieses mal habe
ich es tatsächlich auf kamera ich muss
erstmal ein bisschen chillen und darauf
klar kommen finde ich an sich eine coole
idee die beschreibung so relativ kurz
und prägnant zu halten die märkte
wahrscheinlich bei mir selber schon
wahrscheinlich hat er sogar von mir
geklaut ich versuchen letzter zeit die
ersten drei zeilen der beschreibung halt
wirklich zu nutzen
mit den zuschauern kurz zusammenzufassen
was im video passiert
er sagt nur das komische dinge passiert
sind bevor wir uns das video jetzt aber
wirklich dann mal anschauen schauen uns
erst mal paar kommentare an also warum
ist die angelschnur nicht in der bild
mangels nur
ich dachte werden geist gute drei
doppelpunkt 06 man sieht die nylonschnur
so eine verarsche like damit es alle
sehen lasst euch nicht verarschen seien
erstmals deutlich die durchsichtige
angelschnur hör auf damit leicht damit
der es hieß ich weiß nicht ob kommentare
gelöscht werden dass leute auch nicht
nur gesehen haben das will ich ihm gar
nicht unterstellen aber wir kommen jetzt
wirklich mal zu dem moment wo wir
wirklich auf das video reagieren meine
freunde hier ist an der tu und
eigentlich wollte ich ja heute ein video
drehen aber warum sagst du eigentlich
wolltest du heute ein video drehen du
drehst gerade ein video sachen die ich
hierhin stelle hier so in dieser area
bugattis dinge stehen manchmal fallen
sie einfach so unter wir hatten jetzt
kann focus ein gebrochenes class tellers
kaputt gegangen ich werde versuchen auf
kamera festhalten dass diese dinger
runter fallen also dafür dass das ganze
eigentlich gefaked ist es ist schon
krasse aufwand er betreibt also ich
meine ich jetzt als kleines elfjährige
sei man deswegen würde ich echt sein
alter oder könnte wirklich was passieren
alles klar
okay okay
ja
vollkommen okay 3060 dollar also wir
gehen es ist ernst dann versteckte doch
wenigstens wenn du das so nach films wie
soll ich sagen
der marc marquez war der geist mark
marke
aber gut ich meine hier hat er seine
zuschauer verarscht der hat irreführende
text geschrieben
das kann man ja mal machen da springt
youtube doch nicht direkt drauf an
naja wir schauen uns mal ein anderes
video vor dem anpfiff halt auch sehr
cool dass auf seinem kanal als erstes
video 24 stunden pappkartons angezeigt
wir das ist ja eigentlich komplett ganz
vernünftiges video der titel ist nicht
den camps geschrieben und wahrscheinlich
passiert sogar wirklich da muss ich
wirklich sagen was man nicht sagen indes
you was sich allerdings nicht verstehe
ist natürlich okay die beschreibung
nachdem ihr über 100.000 daumen hoch
geschafft hat blablabla das komisch ist
aber das ende family friendly
warum steht da unten family friendly
habt ihr sicherlich die debatte
mitbekommen dass sehr viele videos von
bekannten youtuber nicht mehr
monetarisiert werden können weil der
kontinent gezeigt wurde leider nicht für
den otto normal youtube nutzer bestimmt
ist bzw
na ja ich sag mal geeignet ist man kann
zum beispiel an seinem handy jetzt
mittlerweile bei youtube app den safe
filter aktiviert dann bekommt man nur
noch videos angezeigt ich wirklich
sozusagen family friendly sind sowie
youtube das sagt uns eine des ju
schreibt es einfach in seiner
beschreibung damit er wahrscheinlich
angezeigt wird wenn eltern family
friendly da eingeben also muss ich sagen
ist das ist schon ne haßloch taktik aber
es ist eine taktik also die in diesem
video in schotten die beschreibung ganz
unten bei mir wäre ich 1000 mark hamill
ihr ein schreiben vielleicht mache ich
dann endlich zu viel klicks wie seinem
des ewz aber wir kommen wieder zurück
zum wesentlichen und zwar seinen
hochgeladenen videos wir schauen uns
jetzt mal hier ein video an ich höre auf
mit den videos bevor ihr wirklich auf
das video draufsteht was ich von mir
schon mal gesagt sein nein er hört nicht
auf mit videos das video geht nur
darüber dass er vielleicht aufhören wird
täglich hochzuladen und dann lässt er
halt hier seine user entscheiden und
sagt sie sollen daumen hoch da lassen
denn er weiter täglich hochladen sollten
daumen runter wenn er nicht mehr hoch
laden soll
der drückt darin als zuschauer und fan
von sam interview auf den daumen runter
war dachte scheiße das ist einfach nur
eine taktik um likes zu bekommen also
wir sehen ja auch hier schon 176.000
darum hochschieben tausend würde ich bin
auch wirklich für daumen hoch kommen
habe ich auch wirklich bock drauf hast
du mehr täglich hoch ist muss er
wirklich sagen bei der ganzen kritik die
ich jetzt hier gerade anbringen an
seinem konto
in den tanks oder eine beschreibung oder
wir leute verarschen seinen videos und
so weiter und so fort ich muss wirklich
sagen er hat innovative ideen ist ein
kreatives gehirn das bild hier zeigt das
jetzt vielleicht nicht so also ich muss
wirklich sagen zeit mit dessen wände
dass sie sich ab respekt vor dir sowas
wird einer der ersten youtube und bist
auch jetzt noch ein youtuber aber ich
meine idee nämlich friendly in die
beschreibung zu schreiben oder einen
einer und schuhhandel öfters machen und
sagen es ist ein geist darauf kommt
wirklich nicht jeder einer der meist
vielleicht ist ein kommentare unter dem
video ist hör auf du [ __ ] community
geht auch sehr nett miteinander um hier
du mist geburt geh nach hause weinen
buhre halt dein maul freundlichkeit
wieder ganz groß geschrieben den
kommentaren aber ich meine das video
hier ist gar nicht so schlimm also wie
es wird schon ein paar mal ein bisschen
[Musik]
durchgereicht schon wieder aber dann
geht's wirklich noch ein video auf dem
kanal das hat er vor 20 uhr opladen das
hat mich wirklich geärgert und da muss
ich sagen das war der auslöser dass das
heute das
das heimen des teams stopp werden
übrigens wenn ihr andere youtuber
gestoppt haben werden wollten seien
passt dass ich das übernehmen soll dann
schreibt andere youtuber die kommentare
schlange versus hamster wer gewinnt da
muss ich wirklich sagen die idee hatte
diesmal tatsächlich nicht von jack bauer
aus amerika geklaut sondern einfach von
facebook auf facebook existieren häufig
videos krokodil böse schlange und dann
denkt jeder das profil gewinnen dabei
dann regelt sich die schlange zehnmal um
das krokodil und tötet den und ich meine
wir menschen interessieren uns für alles
was irgendwie krass ist und wenn wir
sehen dass zwei der starke tiere
aufeinander treffen und sich boxen dann
klicken wir natürlich drauf genauso bei
schlange versus hamster die community
von seiner desto weiß dass er ein
hamster hat der liegt bei ihm in der
wohnung und jetzt hat er sich
anscheinend auch eine schlange gekauft
denkt jetzt natürlich der normale sei
mit der zuschauer das hier ist das video
wir sehen neben der standard anzeige zu
beginn und am ende vier mit rot ist in
ordnung muss ich sagen bei den heutigen
zeiten natürlich meistens drei mitrovica
mehr macht jetzt vier baby macht
beispielsweise so immer so 40.000 da
muss ich wirklich sagen bin ich komplett
auf seiner seite die takes a decent
arena bisher an das snack ist noch
komplett in ordnung kann man machen real
snake ist falsch weil die schlange
einfach eine gummi schlange samstag ist
auch noch richtig challenge neuer als
ist jetzt nicht wirklich eine challenge
aber ich würde mal sagen geht auch noch
klar in python ist es jetzt auch nicht
es ist immer noch eine gummi schlange
how to catch the snake in kambodscha
warum schreibt er orte catches weg
kambodscha ihm die texte ja bist du nach
kabul geflogen hat da der gummi schlage
gefangene als zwei takes von sechs sind
richtig man könnte jetzt sagen okay das
video meldung legen ihre führenden text
aber ich meine schauen dass man noch ein
ok ok hallo hallo hallo activity
schlangen rein
doch die schlange ein sehr sehr gute
taktik sport quasi so ein bisschen zu
beginnen aber erst hat nicht alles also
der tina das ganze event nur ein
bisschen an das heißt der normale
zuschauer muss jetzt natürlich das video
komplett durchschauen damit er die szene
nochmal sieht oder passiert wie es gibt
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen hier
durch und wahrten quasi darauf dass das
ganze mit der schlange passiert hier
essen die mikrofonen da ist seine frau
freundin keine ahnung was das wieder
seine freundin da hat eine brille auf
hier schaut in die kamera hier zeigen
sie kekse da sind kommentare hier sind
diese vom laptop
was passiert das überhaupt
das ist alles von jd paul geklaut das
ist ja nicht mehr normal dass sich ja
jetzt erst jackpot ich kenne das ist
einer der größten amerikanischen
youtuber er hat über sieben oder acht
millionen abonnenten er macht derzeit
das größte wachstum glaube ich von allen
kanälen weltweit auf youtube man sieht
wirklich schon relativ früh dass ich
sein wenn erst die beispielsweise bei
diesem tag oder bei diesen kommt er so
ein bisschen an jack pauli orientierter
der nämlich auch auf diesen blauen
hintergrund knallige farben ist an sich
alles überhaupt kein problem ich
orientiere mich selber häufig beisammen
mails von anderen youtube und aber naja
das mit dem auto fahren jetzt schon ein
bisschen kraft will jetzt aber trotzdem
mal sehen ob wir überhaupt irgendwas mit
der schlange passiert hatte ich meine
ich wirklich das video durch und
irgendwie passiere gar nichts oder
brille auf ihr da da da da hamster börse
schlange seid ihr bereit für die
schlange
ich dachte ich meinen humor werden am
schönen epische musik im hintergrund die
schlange wird reingesetzt freunde wir
haben es irgendwie schlange leute denken
ich würde diesen lieben haben sie eine
schlange vorsätzen ja weil es im titel
steht und in den text reals naked snake
eater boccia wenn du real snake inditex
schreibst natürlich geht man davon aus
das ist eine echte schlange ist das was
jetzt hier von heutigen ausgabe dieser
youtube muss gestoppt
übrigens auch hier wieder im
videoverleih friendly effekt die
beschreibung ab ganz unten ist emily
freundlich und spam family freundlichen
kommentare damit ich weltweit
familienfreundlich da mensch werde wenn
euch das video gefallen hat das gerne
mal like der findet jetzt hier oben ein
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnt ihr einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren findet ihr auf meinen job
eingeblendet in dem in drei tagen drei
neue produkte launischen werden und ihr
und den pearson irgendwas anderes aber
kein sammelt es die video
das video nicht so ernst bitte